well joining me now is author and
historian Tessa Dunlop by the author of
The Palace papers Tina Brown in America
by Royal historian author of the new
book after Elizabeth can the monarchy
save itself welcome to all three of you
team let me start with you
very much the queen of Royal experts in
my opinion so what is the queen of Royal
experts view as we incredibly it's a
year tomorrow I can remember every
moment of that day
um but it's a year tomorrow that we lost
uh Elizabeth II I do I do feel a lot of
the magic died with the queen of the
monarchy what do they do about this
well you know I actually think that
Charles has actually gripped it in a way
that's very surprising actually I I
wouldn't really agree that it's all gone
away and all drained away I think that
in a strange way the chaos that you
vividly describe at the top of the show
has actually made Charles look a lot
better he's suddenly the great Statesman
on the world stage he's the most August
Statesman that England can really put
out there he's become a huge National
Asset and he really hasn't put a foot
wrong in the last year I agree that has
actually I think sort of surprised
everybody so that's good and you've got
the sparkle coming out of Kate and
William so I think that's not a bad
double Act of of Charles being the kind
of August grandfather of the country and
Sparkle Sparkle from William and Kate
here's the problem I don't think it's
quite as dire well here's why I think it
may be a little more diet than you think
and maybe not as dire as the picture I
painted I'm certainly a massive fan of
King Charles and queen Camilla I think
they're fantastic and done a great job I
think stabilizing things after what was
a very unstable period but young people
people in particular according to all
the polls at the moment 37 of 18 to 24
year olds want the monarchy to continue
40 on elected head of state only 30
percent think the royal family is good
value for money these are worrying
numbers for the Royals and it seems to
me that when I talk to young people they
all had great reverence and I think
interest in the queen but they're not so
reverential or interested in the others
at the moment it's not irretrievable but
at the moment I think there's a kind of
malaise
well you know I have to say that if
you'd ask people young people in the
1960s if they had a great reference for
the queen they would have absolutely
thought she was a complete boar you know
I mean when you had all those irreverent
shows like that was the week that was
that was a period where the queen was
very much out of fashion she was
considered irrelevant
I don't think that if you had polling at
that time with all the young people at
that moment they would have particularly
thought the queen was this fabulous icon
that she became in a strange way the
last 20 years of the Queen's life sort
of was the most iconic time for her I
would actually argue that uh Stephen
frizz filmed the queen where with Helen
Mirren was a beginning of a kind of Pop
Culture Embrace of the queen where she
went from being someone irrelevant to
young people to suddenly being almost
like a sort of hip pop culture icon and
you had the thing with the uh her
wonderful appearance of the Olympics and
you had then she was packed with
Paddington Bear and all of a sudden the
queen was kind of co-opted by by pop
culture and she in her brilliant way
embraced it but I'm not sure that you
would have found young people thinking
she was so fabulous when she was in her
interesting point all right says you've
been gagging to get in here as always
um I mean I I think there are a lot of
distractions going on at the moment
you've got the Harry and Megan thing
you've got the prince Andrew Scandal
still bubbling away we're apparently to
see the files on him now for some huge
amount of time for reasons that
completely baffle me
um you've got
problems I think for Charles and what
kind of monarchy he wants to present to
the world what's he going to change and
you've got William and Kate who I think
are doing a great job
um but come on the numbers when you
agreed with me that there was a ball
drop around the Women's World Cup that
was a mistake a clear way he could have
got some Headway with young people
William
I've made it very clear Williams should
have got on the first plane out to that
World Cup final and watched the
lionesses that he's a president of EFA
for goodness sake it was ridiculous but
actually that spoke to a deeper
stubbornness and dare I say entitlement
and you put once again if I may you put
all the blame on little pretty
Irrelevant in some respects Harry when
if what about all the blame on him
at the top and I took notes on it I put
a lot of extensive note I put a lot of
blame on those a lot of blame because
they're the only the only two members of
the royal family who have done what
they've been I'm sure Ed your academic
will agree with me that the the broad
shoulders it should be anyway the broad
show that institutional monarchy that
has to be where change comes from
whether it is the Redemptive Olive
Branch offered to Harry it needs to come
from his father from his brother who are
part of an institution of State not from
a prince who wears a beanie and goes
around you know Europe doing a
well-meaning charity gigs no it needs to
come from the the institution of
monarchy and actually deeper change you
mentioned their transparency access to
files Freedom of Information that needs
to come from the monarchy they need to
lead you're right call out the politics
politicians they're rotten we need to
see leadership from Charles Ed you wrote
a piece about all this uh pretty much
affirming uh that there is a rut in the
royal family like I said I don't think
it's irretrievable but I do sense it I
do sense there's been a kind of down
downturn if you like but we've been
through these before and they've bounced
back but what where do you think we are
with the royal family and the
institution of the monarchy and do you
see a way that they can get things back
on track
will actually appears I think you're I
think you're right there is something of
a rut here and I I have to briefly and
respectfully take issue with something
that Tina said before the opinion polls
in the 1960s that were taken there
weren't many of them but many young
people were asked more than 60 said that
the the queen represented The Best of
British uh and I think that was really
significant you know we've only got to
go back 10 years to 2013 and 72 percent
of young people were saying uh that the
monarchy would continue that they
supported it and that it was here to
stay
fast forward 10 years and things have
definitely changed and I think uh the
news and hubbub around Andrew and more
recently uh Harry and Megan are partly
to do with it but I think there's
something bigger here as well I think
there is a significant generational
divide over the monarchy just as there
is a significant significant General
divide in society more generally
regarding the state of the nation young
people under 45s especially and most
acutely the under 25s are totally
disenchanted with the state of modern
Britain and I think the monarchy as a
symbol at the heart of the country is
taking a lot of flack yeah I think
that's right Tina
Harry and Megan I don't particularly
like talking about them anymore I think
it's become a it's just a Relentless
kind of Groundhog Day thing really they
want attention they want to make money
out of the royal titles every time they
rear their heads to do it everyone I
hear goes nuts including me and then we
carry on repeat cycle
um what is going on with them in America
though I mean what is their reputation
like there now how relevant are they
we're hearing that Megan's planning her
big comeback
etc etc but where are they over there
okay well first of all just to say uh to
Tessa's point I completely agree about
William blowing it with the lionesses
but that's where I missed Harry actually
that's where they missed Harry sure
because you know if Harry had been part
of the mix you know Harry could have
gone to the lionesses wouldn't he have
been fabulous let's face it whatever you
think okay I would say I would say to
that why didn't he
that would have been really cool sorry
nothing nothing was stopping him getting
on a plane if he wanted to and he didn't
so he could have done but he wasn't the
presence
Williams should have gone as president
of the fa that was his duty to do that
and it was a very rare very bad misstep
by him to not do that and also actually
if you're a woman player for the England
team I mean how fast would you have got
on a plane if that'd be the England
men's team in the World Cup final he'd
have been like a greyhound on speed so I
but but Harry could have gone if he
wanted to he did anyway back back to the
bigger picture Harry and Megan in
America it's this brand
well I'll tell you what is interesting
is the fact that Megan's old show 12
years old suits is actually the number
one show at the moment in America nobody
understands why somebody posted a meme
on Tick Tock and the whole thing
exploded it and suddenly suits this old
show is the first is the best viewed
Show on Netflix worldwide go figure
nobody knows and it's not really thought
it's there anything to do with Megan but
it is an interesting thing well it's
actually a very I gotta say it's a very
good show I really liked suits yeah so
it doesn't surprise me I thought it was
great but why it's suddenly been dug out
of the sort of I know it's weird no but
it's not weird it's because they've got
the X Factor which is why we find it
painful when they left it was so painful
but it made as a team that said it's not
necessarily because of Meghan Markle but
let me continue to The Wider point about
how popular they are what do you think
the The Wider point is well just to say
though that in that instance uh
Hollywood agents I speak to kind of say
actually the weird thing is if Megan
wanted to go and make an acting deal
right now she could probably crush it
and get a great acting deal but I don't
think that's what she's looking for
because acting is now way too much hard
work basically there there are none
they're a non-factor here actually I
mean in Hollywood nobody talks about
them at all I'm told that they just
they're just you know the whole
celebrity canvas is so much bigger wider
and hotter they're not really a factor
they're just they're just miners who
show up at celebrity events and so on so
there's nothing really going on with
their brand uh here and I think that
they've really got to figure out
obviously they have taken advice finally
and gone quiet which is exactly what
they should have done like shut up like
go away and they have gone away for the
entire summer but they've got to figure
out what archwell is you're like what's
it for you know what is it what is it
actually for they haven't raised very
much money with it to be honest I mean I
think it's 12 or 30 million dollars or
something you think by now it'll be 100
million
the problem they've got is they actually
the only currency they have so far that
has proved remotely interesting to the
public is when they're trashing their
families and I I find that pathetic and
sad and it's caused unbelievable risks
not just with his family with her family
the poor father sitting there 50 miles
away has never met his grandchildren
he's never met the person that married
his daughter despite bringing up Megan
on his own for years you know all of it
is just incredibly on a human family
level incredibly sad uh and I you know
they keep talking about how happy they
are over there how happy could anybody
be if you're estranged from both of your
families I mean I just don't know how
can you be happy is there vulnerability
and I agree there is a vulnerability
because they're outside the institution
but I I don't know what Adam Tina feel
about this but that's why I believe that
the rapprochemore the olive leaf the
move towards making they're never going
to be a happy family of again but some
kind of Redemptive has to come from the
King but hang on hang on he's made
efforts to do this the problem is they
don't trust Harry anymore they believe
he's going to be taping them recording
them making notes doing stuff for future
something kind and loving does it matter
if you're taped my son I am told Charles
has tried multiple times to do this but
Harry wants them to apologize to him for
the damage he's been reeking on the
royal family there's young people
let's face it though I mean
it is not in Megan's interest to have
her approximal between Harry and his
family that's why I don't think it'll
happen because Megan does not want to
live in England ever again nope she
feels that England was just uh you know
rejected her she rejects it uh she finds
it cold boring nothing for her she loves
her you know the Hollywood we apparently
said tonight she wants to be yeah he
apparently said tonight in his speech
that this charity event that his wife
was really sorry she couldn't be there
that's complete nonsense she's not sorry
she can't be there she was up two
Beyonce concerts last week if she wanted
to be there she'd be there
um she doesn't want to be there for the
reasons
and then the Hope got taken away and
that's why you know what if you trash
your family in public in the way that
they've done for so long eventually any
family would go that's it drawbridge
down done and that's sadly where we are
incredible that he's here Harry and he's
not going to see his brother or his
father
everything I will say about that is this
this family has never been a
touchy-feely family I mean you know they
never rushed to family reunions except
at Christmas Easter you know this is not
a family that is all over each other
yeah at the best of times yeah and quite
obviously Harry's completely alienated
his family and it's done I I don't quite
understand why Journal you know English
coverage is constantly about and he
comes to England and he hasn't seen his
family no they're stretched no no I
agree No One's Gonna rush I totally
agree we're gonna leave it there Tina
Brown lovely to see you uh good to see
you Tessa Ed Owens after Elizabeth can
the monarchy save itself actually a
really interesting book about the future
of our monarchy here does it have a
future how long is that future I hope it
does I think it will but work to be done
by King Charles he's doing a great job
but work to be done in reshaping now the
monarchy in His image for what he wants
for us and the country uh great to see
you all thank you very much indeed